next with my collar from the six one two
area code caller from six one two go
ahead Hey Baby this is Keith from
Louisiana how's it gone good go ahead
deep uh so yeah I'm kind of freaking out
about this whole Baltic state bulking
the state thing I don't think this is
getting enough attention I mean we got
to be clear that this wasn't somebody
saying ball Balkan when they met Baltic
this is the president yes he now with
the heads of state from Baltic countries
and then slapping his jaw about
Yugoslavia this is I mean these are NATO
member states not only that they're
arguably the most vulnerable NATO member
states to any Russian aggression yes so
for people who don't know what you're
talking about just to give you the
15-second version Donald Trump a few
months ago met with the leaders of the
Baltic States Estonia Latvia and
Lithuania and clearly thought he was
meeting with leaders of Balkan states
which are a thousand miles away in
Europe are other countries and he kind
of criticized the leaders of the Baltic
States for starting wars that led to the
breakup of Yugoslavia in the early 90s
which of course it didn't because that's
the Balkans not the Baltics and it just
it was a total embarrassment and you're
right it's not getting that much
attention like it's insane that that
story is not getting more attention its
25th amendment to me this is why we have
the 25th amendment I mean this clearly
demonstrates he's not competent to run a
country no doubt and I mean what would
happen like honestly I don't know that
we would react at all if say five
hundred to a thousand like on it's like
secret Russian soldiers moved across the
border into Estonia and started you know
fortifying a ethnic Russian village yeah
I think I don't know I don't know if we
would I mean Trump wouldn't know where
it is but you you bring up a good point
Keith and there it sounds like buttons
are being pressed and there's a weird
audio thing so I'm gonna let you go but
very well-made point
and I do appreciate it and it's an
absolute embarrassment that the fact
that Trump is criticizing world leaders
for starting wars that they didn't start
that their countries didn't start it's
it's an absolute shame and and an
embarrassment